just a couple of days before discovery
series 4 was expected to appear on
netflix around the world
it got pulled but not only is series 4
pulled
but series 1 2 and 3 as well
what the hell is going on with paramount
and cbs welcome to scitrek your sci-fi
tv and movie channel
enterprise discovery is not my favorite
star trek iteration at all
i find it quite annoying at times but it
has been getting better
so why on earth would netflix dump
ep series one two and three offered
service
two or three days before we were
expecting serious four to appear
well
paramount and cbs have decided
that they're not going to allow the
worldwide rights as they normally would
to go to the highest bidder and they're
going to keep discovery serious for for
themselves
the plan is that some point next year
paramount plus
will have become a streaming service
worldwide like it is in america
up until now i believe americans please
correct me if i'm wrong but up until now
star trek in america has been on cbs all
access
but they are pushing forwards with a
paramount plus channel a channel they
hope to compete with disney now it seems
they're pulling discovery back from the
worldwide distribution on netflix that
it has been done for the last few years
so they can premiere discovery on
paramount plus when it does go
eventually worldwide
now that has pissed me off
and
many other fans as well why do that this
close why do that only a few days before
we were expecting to actually see the
damn show
but also
are they going to do this with picard
series 2 we have no confirmation that's
going to appear on amazon as the last
series did
how about series 3 of lower decks are we
not going to get to see that either
there are other iterations of star trek
like strange new worlds being planned
that we again have no news on what
channel that's going to be on is that
because again that is going to be held
back for paramount plus
are we going to lose star trek
completely for at least a year
it does seem likely to me and i've
argued talking about stargate in the
past that i don't actually think amazon
are pushing forwards with
star trek anyway i don't think they're
particularly interested in star trek i
think they want to bring stargate back
something that'll be their baby that
they can have complete control over
netflix though would have wanted to keep
star trek as its worldwide franchise
that is their big sci-fi show on their
channel
star trek
even if you don't really like the modern
iterations of it is still very popular
even though picard didn't do as well for
amazon as they'd hoped so i do again i
think that leads into maybe amazon not
being all that bothered that if
paramount plus do sort of decide to hold
on to the rights of star trek for
themselves i don't think they'll be too
gutted so why has this happened
basically disney did this with the
marvel
on disney on netflix they had the
punisher
daredevil jessica jones and the
terrible iron fist oh and luke cage luke
h a tv show i couldn't even be asked to
watch and i'm a massive geek i watched
the first series i got about
four episodes into the second series
i've no idea it ended
um but they did the same thing with
disney plus they wanted to have those
shows for themselves they didn't want
netflix to have them they didn't want
netflix to completely
have be in direct competition with
disney plus when it became a thing and
now there was more and more rumors that
actually deda was going to return to
disney plus now that the contract that
they had with netflix is run its course
paramount plus seem to be planning the
same thing and using star trek to do
that that they're going to want a big
franchise on the new channel and
star trek is going to be it and at the
end of the day star trek is an
incredibly expensive show to make
a lot of the cost of the show was
actually recouped simply through
netflix's investment because netflix
obviously paid a massive fee to
paramount and cbs to have the show's
worldwide rights
paramount are giving up about money
they're saying at the moment we don't
want it especially considering the
worldwide economic situation covid and
everything else you know a lot of
entertainment things have been really
suffering so hey it's a brave move i tip
my hat to you if that's the plan but i
am telling you this paramount plus
i already pay for loads of streaming
services
if i'm going to pay for paramount it
ain't going to be because of star trek
you are going to have to do something
really impressive to get me to fork over
any of my cash
i don't even like the fact that i pay
for disney
you know i already pay for disney amazon
prime and picking netflix and i don't
watch them half the time
so you're really gonna have to do
something amazing
the wish for this though the thing that
i really wanna i wanna do this really
quick video is because this is just
maddening
whoever at the executive level thought a
paramount that this was a good idea
doing it this late in the day have they
got no forward planning did they just go
at some point in a meeting oh netflix
called
they were wondering when when they're
going to get a copy of discovery series
four and somebody's gone no we forgot to
tell them oh damn it
it's not like they've been invited to a
party and they've just remembered last
minute that they didn't want to go
you know
a
terrible organization and i really hope
that the fans walk the fans vote with
their feet here and refuse to get
paramount plus when it is become a
stream of service worldwide and just
don't watch this damn show and because
to be honest it's not that good anyway
so thanks for watching please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out and tell me what you
think about paramount plus pulling this
pigging trick
please go join us on facebook there's a
link in the description and there's also
a discord server where you can go and
talk to like-minded sci-fi enthusiasts
and tell us exactly what you think of
this absolute balls up
i will see you next time guys hopefully
with some slightly better news
[Music]
you